will you ever get more teeth welcome to
another episode of not too deep with
grace helbig my audio / video podcast
Thank You me if you don't know this
works by now I swear to god I'm going to
hunt you down and just for you
I won't anyway here's how it works I
bring on some YouTube friends of mine to
get interviewed I show you a little bit
of that interview portion here on its
grace along with a game that I also
force them to play why are they my
friends the games are inspired by
challenges that already exist on YouTube
and then I kind of read told them to
make them real dumb but if you want to
listen to the interview portion in its
entirety you can go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud and listen to the audio by
subscribing to not too deep with grace
Helbig some very simple system this week
Mike and vary from sorted food are you
guys ready did you say Randy ready good
are you Randy yeah this is so exciting
thank you guys for being here with me
today we're starting or starting this is
it here with Mike and berry from sorted
food how you guys feeling ecstatic
nervous how are your butt's feeling
wobbly yeah you're sitting on the
fanciest chair couch we could find and
it's an interactive experience because
the circle spin so here's my first
burning question do you think you could
fit more tissues in your mouth or your
butthole hmm
Wow tissues remember like thinking about
tissue it's like they can get smaller
yeah well I teach it varies there is a
logical answer to this uh-huh
you'd probably say you bum yeah because
if you'd stuck to him in his mouth you'd
die
well they were just dissolved right when
tis you wanna get wet baby I mean it
depends how far you go up because the
lower intestine is a mile long isn't it
I don't know yeah is it okay so I dig
your ear because you man
sent Amelie Turner five if sex and
alcohol were about to be uninvented
which one would you save oh wow yeah sex
or alcohol which would you save
what are we considering humanity because
that's pre just so I mean that's gonna
be a judge of your character which one
you consider huh I've got sex yeah I'd
love to keep sex yeah it's more useful I
think that's good for procreation for
the rest of the world cuz otherwise the
humanity would die but also imagine
sober sex and that's Jacob asked how do
you have sex brilliantly almost a little
bit like if I pretend really with a lot
of enthusiasm maybe Larry will come
across that in what did it just bury you
pick em Giardina wants to know boxers or
briefs boxes boxes not for yourselves
just in life boxes look says alright
there's no two ways about I'm just
making sure that your opinions are tight
and real a flower is crucial you know
what I heard recently that the the hole
in the front of the boxers when if
something happens to slip through the
hole let's say that they call it a dead
man falling out of windows
okay okay you might have some
assumptions of what Challenger got to do
you are huge people something like
recognized so yep okay Oh hit my nose
just that is Limoge enough Larry so
normally on YouTube there is the Saltine
challenge where you are challenged to
eat six saltines in one minute so today
instead of the Saltine challenge we will
be playing the sardine jalan
normally in the Saltine challenge you to
eat six saltines in one minute today we
have to eat six so I can't even say the
word sardines as fast as we can and we
can't use our hands Oh big problems of
this yeah this is gonna be a little bad
I have never had a sardine before and
they look justified on the whole come on
sister your invention yeah you just
explained the logistics of what was
their logistics is hands behind your
back when I say go it's face balmy the
first person to eat all six are
deflation six because that's just X
these are chains if you want them in
between there's a house for those yeah
you can use a hand Rosen for the beer
okay you just can't use it for the
sardines on your marks
Oh get set go
oh stop it
come on my mouth
you can address yet skin not anymore
how about you dip it I'm gonna say Mike
100 siding down congratulations Mike
I'll smash that Cheers
preserver
go subscribe assorted food however on
YouTube and don't forget to check out
the full interview on iTunes not too
deep with grace Helbig you got balls
I'm belly full of a school of fish there
you go that was disgusting but good job
for Mike I guess ladies he's single and
has terrible breath cuz he eats sardines
also make sure you go check out they
have a sorted food app now for your
phone called sorted it's like Instagram
but for food and it's really really cool
and I support them because they ate
sardines on camera with me did you see
very gagging that wasn't fake that was a
real gag reflex like a cartoon he uh god
bless him anyone listen to the full
interview go over to iTunes SoundCloud
great zombocom click the link in the
description below look for natural deep
with grace Helbig I don't know
sorry weird watching handsome men eat
sardines isn't it there's like a lot of
emotions that go on